hey how's it going main review main
review name review that's right
welcome to soo Sweden's favorite show
that's right do download a free meme
review Mamma Mia
oh my dad do we have some great memes
this week I have been saving up these
are such good meme said I don't even
know where to begin
first meme FBI is watching me oh my god
this meme is so funny these people on
Twitter are saying that the FBI is
watching them through this webcam hi
webcam cray FBI hi keys you don't know
what I'm talking about here but here's
an example me smiling to the FBI agent
moderating me through my laptop camera
before I browse for bird okay that one's
funny what whatever this mean Matt
garner did a lot of a lot of mean major
media Newsom in for Anakin how do I not
speak at this point this meme has got a
lot of media attention guys I just
sneeze in front of my laptop's webcam
and I kid you not the FBI agent said
bless you if that isn't goals I don't
know what is we're just trying to be
nice to the FBI man me opens laptop FBI
int oh he's finally gonna do his
homework me opens up Netflix and
disappoint yet another person in my life
I am such a failure oh that's hilarious
even the mail online the Daily Mail
posted about this mean that's how you
know it's good that's how you know it's
a
it's a tongue kisses laptop webcam
before bed goodnight mr. FBI man a
hundred thousand retweets a hundred
thousand retweets that was a you did you
retweet that [ __ ] go away go away
I'm not talking to you I'm talking to
the FBI man of course for real though
those furry website that was Edgar this
means sort of place on the paranoia that
for some reason anyone would give us no
but what's going on in your life when in
fact they don't and yes
this meme is garbage this is a garbage
mean we found another one this is almost
as bad at that god-awful skedaddle meme
all right at least one of them made me
laugh skadoosh g'day
[Music]
I'm gonna let this one slide you know I
know that never happened I never laughed
at them and I never ever ever will laugh
at an FBI man meme disgusting despicable
I'm spitting because I am so upset about
this meme I'm giving it a five pastas
that's the lowest ranking we have ever
given it that's how bad it is now I know
that you are pretty upset and I'm upset
too about this how bad of a mean this
was so if I should put our the robotic
Overlord himself a man with no heart and
no soul clearly loves a nice upon now
he's joined the community of isopod
lovers finally the eyes of our community
on YouTube will thrive I've been trying
to get it active for jeers
can we get isopods trending can it
happen how hard can we shield is me next
[Music]
how do I do this mean without swaying
this is gonna be kind of annoying you're
so precious why are you this meme is
fantastic it's sort of bad why don't we
have a look
ooh so precious why are you
from the back driving this meme is sort
of parroting those god-awful tumblr
edits that you see everywhere people put
it way too much
pictures of people that we're not safe
and we're seeing Spain where's the gun
some would say people are using this
meme now ironically that's not the case
they do it because they love beautiful
beautiful there's so many beautiful
variations of this wait a minute
sight sigh what are you doing you're
supposed to add it for me might not
making this I don't know if cyber brat
is editing this one what do you do it
you're supposed to make memes for me
this is what you do on your spare time
making silly names from the back
[Music]
lose my cellphone indoors
Oh what else do we got back in that
you're so precious meme it's a it's sort
of taken it sprout I can see a lot of
this go in a lot of different ways uh it
just required a lot of editing skill to
acquire or at least some to make a
decent and thus it would probably only
go so far but nonetheless a nice little
mean that we can all laugh at ha ha that
was funny
can i rate this meme for an f5 that's
what this one gets next me ok guys if
you are under the age of 18 click away
this video now because it's about to get
really really scary really really spooky
so be careful make sure at least a
parental guardian is by your side we're
gonna watch a scary video number 15
Burger King foot lettuce the last thing
you'd want in your Burger King burger is
someone's foot fungus know the number 15
[Music]
stupid this meme is fantastic it started
from top 15s channel making a video of
the top 15 mysteries solved by fortune
and the very first video baby begins
like this Burger King foot lettuce the
last thing you'd want in your Burger
King burger is someone's foot fungus but
as it turns out that might be what you
get number how do does he do that stupid
voice number 15
no number number 15 number 15 Burger
King foot
the last thing you want in your burger
King burger is foot fungus but as it
turns out that might be what you get why
does he talk like that and why I have so
many questions
the observe absurdity observa T
absurdity of this clip made for some
nice some nice memes here it's done in a
silly Pig last thing you'd want in your
burger King burger in someone's flip
phone yes
completely turning the video around
incredible it used to be so spooky
[Music]
burger king foot lettuce the last thing
you'd want in your burger king burger is
someone's foot [ __ ] yes but as it turns
out that might be what you get I don't
know why it's funny it's just so dumb
there's of course that number 9 Big
Smoke ordering the last thing you want
okay all right okay okay listen we're
sort of turning to the petting dog mean
but would feet instead goosebumps foot
lattice addition their spook ears of the
mouth normal foot lattice aha
Burger King foot lettuce that's our
number 15 everyone knows that gonna rape
the Burger King foot lettuce it gets a
fine cuz it's okay how about this Burger
King foot lettuce we start off on a five
baseline against two plus points four
foot lettuce miners 1.4 15 and plus yeah
I don't know it gets the rating I guess
next me no actually we're done oh where
we have time for me bonus this meme is
gonna be there you know I'm something
I'm a scientist myself meme oh watch the
science whiz you know I'm something of a
scientist myself taking this beautiful
wonderful foreshadowing scene in
spider-man and turning it into a
beautiful bonus mean when you put water
in the freezer and it freezes to ice
then you bring it out and it melts back
to water
you know I'm something of a scientist
myself when someone's talking about
chemistry and you remember salt is
sodium chloride huh yes of course
you know I'm something of a scientist
myself when a lego sets us four to seven
years but you finish building it in
three days you know I'm something of a
scientist myself when you overhear some
normies laughing at a Ugandan knuckles
me but I'm gonna get back when I hear
hot girls at my school talking about
their sex life you know I test myself
when you watch Rick and Morty you know
I'm something of a scientist myself what
someone hits you with a well-constructed
and thought-out roast that hits too
close to home
no you there's something other
scientists meme her a bonus meme hooray
it gets four points that was it for this
week's meme review now I'm actually
gonna go away goodbye
this is my final video I thought it
would be something more sentimental
perhaps some tears
perhaps milking it by reminding you to
buy my merch Lincoln to the buyer buy my
March for real I'm gonna be gone it's
been a pleasure I'm going away for a
holiday to two weeks sayonara goodbye
goodbye guys I'll be back by my merch
[Music]
don't be stop crying stop crying